exactly they also know their assignment
of killing Nazis exactly and you know I
didn't want to say that part but yes yes
no absolutely no that's what it was so
it's like I'm I'm curious to see what
I'm with addict though there is not
trepidation but it's like okay how do
you handle it you're known for first
person you know but we need to see Indie
do you do cinematic flash I mean you
know cinematic Cuts you know with
certain things is it predominantly in
third person and then certain modes of
first first person like s was saying
driving I would be disappointed if it's
primarily in first person i' be super
disappointed it's it's an interesting
thing cuz some people will push back